[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey oh look who has joined the program
the popular rich eisen of the rich eisen
show
and nfl network hi rich dp i was driving
to work i heard your story about
taking uh your kids to the super bowl
yeah
um and um and what what were the names
of the guys that she took pictures of
who was this was this georgia took the
pictures oh no this was grace but it was
like you know jim and tommy
and uh she just took pictures of two
drunk patriots fans
at the game well the first super bowl uh
we took
our kids to was believe it or not
patriots and seahawks
and um and
the fact that the thing that they
remember most about it were the patriots
fans around them as well
dan because they were just chit-chatting
with their own jimmies and toms and mike
the entire game and katy perry comes out
at halftime and i'm sitting in the
stands as well it's the first super bowl
i ever did not work the post game show
so it was the first one i actually sat
in the stands for
myself because i normally would have to
be getting ready to do a post game but
any rate
so katy perry is coming out and she does
her half time and my son
zan is dressed in a tom brady jersey and
he's he's
just dancing his head off and then half
time ends and a patriot fan looks at me
he just waves me over to him and i'm
like okay what are we going to talk
about here
and he just leans over he goes your son
is one hell of a dancer
and they were just all like best friends
the rest of the game
and it was uh one of those things as
well where you said that the game that
you took them to was so
memorable and exciting um yeah i will
tell them like you were you had a front
row seat we were right there in the
mezzanine right on the goal line when
malcolm butler picked off
russell wilson they don't they don't
remember they're literally talking about
katy perry
to this day it's kind of crazy yeah you
know what resonates with them and
and i i just i dropped them off at the
super bowl and i had to host
sportscenter that night and uh
you know then they came back but just to
get my daughter's film developed and all
it was was
these two guys you're like i said
guys so grace what do you what are you
doing she goes dad i just took pictures
and then they
they both passed out like that i think
they got tired and i
it's like it's like the the final
credits to the hangover right like you
get the
you get the camera back
[Laughter]
you don't know what's in it yeah then
you take a look at but i guess the
question i have for you
as well because you mentioned the first
super bowl was
new england versus carolina that was um
that was nfl network's first super bowl
um
i was in the building as well that was
also
the wardrobe malfunction halftime did
you ever have a conversation
with your kids about that one they had
no idea where their seats were rich
they had they couldn't see it they
weren't sure if there was a football
game going on
but you know wow yeah they did
after the fact because my wife goes did
did they see the
you know what happened with janet i go
no
i said hun no they did they did not hey
uh before i let you go
uh the julio jones situation yes sir
where where where
because it feels like it's not if but
when but how about where
i don't know new england sounds the
right spot to me because they can absorb
it
immediately they could truly use him
they're talking about it
and it would make a ton of sense an
absolute ton of sense
um but then you know the report i think
it was
uh it was from diana rossini of espn
um that they they already have a one in
their back pocket that does not sound
like new england to me
although new england is the only team
atlanta could say to when they ask
they say we'll just give you two they're
like well you know that's what we got
from muhammad saneu
let's let's let's realize we're talking
about here right so
um that makes sense the titans would
make a ton of sense too
because they're i just don't see them
trading them within their conference
green bay is the one that makes the most
sense to me dan it really does
it fixes everything you know and i know
this sounds like a fantasy football
trade but telling
atlanta you needed you were looking for
you know
the successor to matt ryan well we've
got him
and um you can take a look at him
yourself he looks great in practice
but his presence is kind of you know
pissing off our mvp quarterback
um and we'll give you we'll give you him
and a two and you give us julio jones
and then you look at
aaron rodgers and you say okay you
wanted to stay here and you wanted the
best possible team as a window of
opportunity
how about the best wide receiver tandem
in football
maybe this entire 21st century how does
that sound
let's go and we've already put aaron
jones on the credit card
and you got big bob tanyan and you let's
go
let's what it kind of makes an insane
amount of sense which means it probably
won't happen
in a million years just want to let you
know that uh
we're on the air
i just want to let you know i should
have told you that up front that we were
yeah but i was going to say i'm out of
nfl network but
um you know now that i know i'm on the
air i'll just keep that to myself
all right uh thank you rich thank you so
much
i can tell when you disapprove i can
tell when you disapprove oh no you paid
it off i didn't want to try to challenge
it i'd let it breathe
[Applause]
[Music]
i should let you look you you should i
should let that's just my fault i should
let you put the button on the
conversation it's your show i'm the
guest my bad dan i'm sorry
yeah i mean you put a bow on it but look
i know i know
humor rich okay
i mean yeah i'll leave it to you dan
mike how many sandler movies have you
been in rich
i've been in a couple of csi miami's dan
so
you know i've got that going there's
nothing funny about csi miami
i disagree sir you and i will have to
have a
conversation at another date but um all
right dan all right
that's rich eisen who joins us on the
program on loan from the nfl network and
the rich eisen show that follows this
one on peak